Cardi B. Gave birth to her third child.
It's a girl. She's beautiful.
Everything's beautiful. The pictures are so cute.
But this one's in there. Look at that face.
Look at her face. Somebody holding her knee.
You have to push that baby out.
And this. I'm so glad she posted this.
Like, look at her face. Look at the pure.
Just exhaustion.
Every emotion you can think of.
It's a journey. Those babies don't come easily.
Don't be fooled by the cute little bows,
the cute little outfits. Oh,
offsets there. But the bigger sister,
the big brother. Look how cute.
Don't. Don't be fooled by how cute,
because it's a fuck. And they don't call it labor for nothing.
Congratulations, by the way. Happy Friday.